Keegan lo is covering this Wake Forest
scandal winston-salem journal is where
he works and kind enough to join us
Keegan good morning when did you first
hear about this story we got word
yesterday that the news was going to
break on that something was coming down
from Wake Forest obviously they started
this investigation almost for four and a
half weeks ago now before the louisville
game and mid-november but there's word
yesterday going around that Wake Forest
had concluded its investigation and I
don't think anyone expected this outcome
but we got word yesterday and then wait
for at least a statement around five
o'clock yesterday afternoon summarized
the story for those who aren't unplugged
in on this how does this how does this
sound nationally if you were going to
explain her so wake forest was going to
play Louisville November twelfth
Louisville obviously with Lamar Jackson
Heisman Trophy one I think they were
number six at the time in the country
and a day before their game on November
twelfth a member of the traveling party
for Wake Forest found some documents
pertaining to wake forest his game plan
in their play call the Friday before
that game coach Dave Clawson became
aware at Wake Forest he told the
director of athletics Ron Wellman and
they investigated it they started their
investigation following the the
louisville game which Louisville 144 to
12 it's been four weeks since they
contacted ACC no one really knew Causton
just referred to it as a security breach
in the days after Louisville but no one
really knew you know if it was something
on Louisville's in something I'll wait
for us in whatever it's been it's been
four weeks since then and then they
announced yesterday obviously that a
Tommy Elrod former player who's a
quarterback in the in the mid 90s and
now he's a radio broadcaster was also a
coach at Wake Forest for 11th season
under former head coach Jim Grobe they
wake forest announced that he had been
leaking information or at least
attempted to leak information on
multiple occasions starting and 2014 a
court
to the press release released by the way
farts yesterday can he be charged can he
be arrested right now he got an attorney
his attorney actually was a teammate of
his at Wake Forest James eek wander he
was a linebacker at Wake Forest in the
90s they overlapped in the early 90s so
so he's got an attorney he appears to be
getting ready to fight something about
it to be charges or or whatever maybe it
appears he's ready to kind of fight this
with with an attorney how widespread is
this I think that's that's the next big
question right i mean obviously
louisville has these documents on the
day before game allegedly and so edit if
it had been going on since 2014 when
Elrod stepped into his role as the radio
broadcaster for Wake Forest and for IMG
I think that's the next question is how
many over three years how many teams
were accepting this information that
Elrod was attempting to give out how
many times did he attempt to give it out
I i think the ATC is going to have some
questions to answer just in the whole
conference in general about you know who
is this three years running now who was
who was accepting this information and
I'm how how why did it go and he was
that angry that he wasn't kept on the
current staff even though he was going
to be part of the radio broadcast team
that he would try to sabotage wake
forest while working for Wake Forest yes
I think there's a lot of different
theories going on right now I think the
number one theory is what you just said
I mean did you have a personal vendetta
coach Clausen was hired after the 2013
season right before the 2014 season
Elrod had been a coach in various
capacities started as a grad assistant
quarterbacks coach and he had been a
coach for 11 years under Jim Grobe cloth
who comes in decides not to retain Elrod
but they give him a job as in a radio
analyst for broadcasting the way for
football games and so I think one period
you know was did he have a personal
vendetta that he wasn't retained I think
you could also it's all kind of
speculation right now I mean what's the
auditioning for other uh trying to be in
good favor with other coaching staffs
around the country you know maybe he
wanted to be a coach again I think some
people have speculated a was money
switching hands I think that's always a
you know gambling because they're
gambling part of this you know money and
so I think there's a lot of different
ways this could go but yeah I think that
the most obvious one that people are
joined conclusions is what's he angry
that he went from Coach to a radio
broadcaster what kind of information
does he have is the radial analyst is he
privy to the entire game plan and
playbook that then he had in his
possession well I think a lot of it also
goes back to the fact that he was a
former player and was of coach so I
don't know if this is just your normal
radio guy you know in terms of just
calling the game or whatever he he I
mean he knows systems and play calls and
defenses and just as good as anyone on
that staff probably you know I mean he's
been a coach 11 years played college
football for so I'm sure he was maybe
let indoors or at least had
conversations with coaches that maybe
some other radio broadcasters wouldn't
have you know I mean and in just terms
of that he knew what was going on and
and he knew how to dissect a playbook
and and break down a defense and when
whatever you may have it well Keegan
good luck it's a interesting story that
there's a few more twists and turns here
I'm sure but thanks for joining us I
think you can appreciate it let's Keegan
low from the winston-salem Journal the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]